PRIYANKA VERGADIA: You're
going through migrating
your monolithic application
to microservices on GKE,
but you've hit a roadblock.
There are so many features and
services in your application,
and you don't know which ones
you should migrate first.
Stay tuned to find out
more in today's episode
of "Get Cooking in Cloud."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
CARTER MORGAN: When you
plan your migration,
it's tempting to
start with features
that are trivial to migrate.
This might be a quick
win, but might not
benefit your project the
most over the long term.
Instead of diving straight
into the migration,
you should spend time
evaluating each feature,
and create a plan
for its migration.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
And to do so, there's
a list of ingredients
that can help.
Start with a business
process evaluation.
Don't forget that this will
be a learning experience,
and there will be
mistakes to learn from.
So for that reason,
the initial efforts
should not involve
business critical systems,
but they should still represent
a significant use case
for the team to learn from.
CARTER MORGAN: From a design
and development point of view,
you want to pick features
that have the least
number of dependencies
and which are
easy to refactor if necessary.
And also consider the costs
and complexity of developing
or refactoring as needed.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: From
operations point of view,
think about features that
can afford the downtime
of the cut-over window.
If you need to
minimize downtime,
migrating features that
require high availability
can mean extra work.
CARTER MORGAN: And
finally, choose
teams that have
well-defined processes
to lead the initial
efforts, because you
want them to lead the way
for this migration journey
and understand that
they will encounter
new challenges for which
they must find solutions.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Taking all
these factors into account,
this recipe calls for
divide and conquer approach,
where we find challenging
but meaningful features.
CARTER MORGAN: The ideal feature
requires little refactoring,
is stateless, has no
external data requirements,
and has few or no dependencies.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Let's
consider our friends
at the ice cream theory
and their migration.
Since they're thinking about a
full migration of their website
to microservices, a good
migration order for them
could be that they migrate
the front end first, then
think about the
stateless features.
Next could be the features
with independent data sets,
such as services that list
their brick and mortar stores.
And then finally, come to
features with shared data sets,
like the business logic
of the platform itself.
CARTER MORGAN: The
platform front end
followed by any
stateless features,
like a currency
conversion system,
go first, because they
usually have few dependents
and often require
limited refactoring.
Because in the initial
migration recipe,
the back end API is
still being served
from the legacy data center
or runtime hosted on premises
or on another cloud.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: After
stateless features,
components whose data sets have
no dependencies on other data
sets, such as services to list
the brick and mortar store,
are the next to migrate.
These are easier to extract
and move to the modern storage
system, like Cloud storage or
Cloud Firestore for managed
data storage, Cloud SQL
for relational data,
or Cloud Firestore or Datastore
for the document based no SQL
data.
CARTER MORGAN: Finally,
features with shared data
sets, like the business logic
of the e-commerce platform,
are the hardest
to migrate because
of the requirements for
consistency, distribution,
access, and latency across
legacy and new services.
Since data migration
is not as simple,
we are dedicating the
entire next episode to it.
Stay tuned.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, there you have it.
If you are looking to migrate
a monolithic application
to microservices, then
you've got a recipe
to decide which features
to migrate first.
Stay tuned for the next episode,
where we will learn about--
CARTER MORGAN: The data
migration strategies.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
That's all for today
on "Get Cooking in Cloud."
CARTER MORGAN: If you would like
to see more content like this,
don't forget to like and
subscribe to our channel.